en cette période de confinement s'il y a
bien une activité partagée par de
nombreux français se sont bien entendu
les séries et une fois n'est pas coutume
en mars et une série made in france qui
a fait l'unanimité sur les plateformes
il s'agit de la série validé diffusée
depuis à peine dix jours et qui a déjà
franchi le cap des 10 millions de
visionnages pour nous c'est un gros
tubes comme d'autres des chiffres
extraordinaires pour une série française
qui a réussi le pari fou de plaire
autant à la critique au grand public un
record absolu de streaming sur my canal
et canal + série depuis leur création
d'autant qu'il s'agit de la toute
première série sur un thème jusque là
jamais abordé dans une oeuvre de cette
ampleur le milieu du rap
si certains pensaient que c'était un
sujet segmentant franck gastambide
habitué au carton avec des comédies
autour de l'univers de la banlieue était
sans conteste le réalisateur le mieux
placé pour s'emparer du sujet validez et
l'histoire d'un jeune rappeur talentueux
apache alias clément qui épaulé par ses
deux amis d'enfance se retrouvent du
jour au lendemain validé par une des
stars du milieu
jma pour parapher du peuple aux boeufs
pour la peau après la pop
mais ce rapprochement va rapidement se
transformer en une dangereuse rivalité
ce cycle un but enfin chamond avec entre
temps un franck gastambide qu'on
retrouve derrière et devant la caméra
pour donner la réplique à un casting
aussi nouveau que rafraîchissant un
succès qui ne risque pas de s'arrêter là
puisque face à l'engouement du public
une deuxième saison est déjà en route
est pour bientôt une série qui est
toujours accessible gratuitement jusqu'à
demain sur canal+
[Musique]
alors les chéris c'est vrai et je vous
racontais parce que valider je vous
racontais s'est passé il joue dur c'est
vrai voilà validé c'est vrai que franck
gastambide qui est vous le savez mon ami
un de mes meilleurs amis vraiment fait
partie du top 2 vous le savez voilà ton
gastambide a développé la série valider
un moment il a proposé à des personnes
de canal et il ya des personnes de canal
plus et c'est leur droit qui ont dit le
rap une série sur le rap ça ne marchera
jamais jamais jamais jamais voilà et et
franck ici il a dit non mais je pense ça
a marché franck a appelé il m'a payée
d'appeler maxime saada le grand patron
de canal+ et gérald brice viret
et c'est vrai que ils se sont saisis
seront s'est tous battus ils se sont
battus pour que la série existe
aujourd'hui c'est le plus grand carton
c'est le record historique pour une
série sur canal + plus de 10 millions de
vu et je vous dis c'est pas seulement
grâce au confinement parce que si la
série avait été nul
forcément ça se serait calmée très vite
mais c'est vrai que c'est un énorme
carton je suis fier de mon frérot est
vraiment je suis tellement content pour
lui et je vous dis c'est un énorme
carton chez que vous êtes plein à
regarder cette série
et la bonne nouvelle c'est que pour ceux
qui sont déjà fans il ya là de la saison
2 qui va être tournée la saison 2 de
cette série la bête qu'on va mener cet
été et franck il est tellement fort
qu'il a déjà l'idée de la saison 3 mon
frère aussi tu me regardes en tout cas
tu sais que je t'aime fort et tu sais
que je suis très très fier de toi comme
je vais servir ce week-end sur un tweet
sur c'est vrai que voilà il ya plein de
gens à canal+ qui ne croyaient pas voilà
qui ne croyaient pas une série sur sur
le rap et il ya plein de gens tout nus
dont la frappe a et bleu franck m'a
appelé j'ai appelé j'oublie gérald brice
viret et maxime saada et finalement on a
rattrapé
franck gastambide au dernier moment pour
qu'il fasse cette série sur canal + donc
merci a toi franck de nous avoir fait
confiance
vous voulez réagir là-dessus les cherry
aurait pas juste moi je veux bien
vas-y non je trouve qu'il a fait part
parce que ils arrivent les jeunes et
rations très très jeune avec la
génération d'anciens il mélange les deux
y joue avec les deux les deux mois moi
j'ai quarante balais je me reconnais
dans la série et je monte il veut qu'à
18 ballet il se reconnaît dans la série
ça c'est super corps d'alain cayzac et
comment il a terminé
sans spoiler comment il a terminé la
saison une je suis curieux de savoir
vraiment je suis pressé de la saison 2
et tout était réglé et tout et tout est
proche de larry de la réalité dans ce qu
il a fait vraiment dans ce qu'il a fait
ses proches de la réalité de ce qui se
passe dans mon pur bain dans le monde la
streak avec des guest stars comme fred
de skyrock et caetera et ses proches de
moi je suis caveau bravo bravo montrant
qu'en tout cas bravo à marguerittes